overnight tonight the scattered  thunderstorms otherwise a mixture of  clouds and stars we will get some wind  gusts early some of it will be outflow  from those thunderstorms to our east 97  tomorrow with some morning clouds mostly  sunny in the afternoon and humidity is  up up up you know the routine highs  tomorrow should be a little warmer  around the century mark and low 100s on  the east side east of the 15 i would say  and also into north las vegas and  regionally about 101 in pahrump boulder  city you're looking at 99. here is your  eight-day outlook and i know this is a  broad brush but i'm telling you we have  a chance of thunderstorms through at  least tuesday and the humidity will be  noticeable every day so  get set to sweat  is that that a way to end a weather cast  well i just did  very muggy